but for whatever reason your lights on
fire in a way that no other part of your
body ever would
[Music]
what up Internet welcome to handle it
online instructional cooking show I'm
Harley aka the Jeff Goldblum of Jamaican
Jerk Chicken aka your dad's favorite
youtuber and today we have a special
guest with us hey what's going on it's
sean evans from hot ones let's get right
into the recipe they're spicy ribs in
honor of the hot one we have here we're
gonna call them too hot for your daddy
ribs and the reason why we're gonna do
that is because yesterday we tested them
out my dad was here they're too hot for
him too hot daddy it's my dad it's too
hot for him too hot for your dad too I
bet so pause the screen right here these
are the steps tools and ingredients you
will need to create the too hot for your
daddy ribs can you tell what's in there
by looking at it and smelling it there's
some cajun spices in there there's some
chili maybe that's it I think that might
be it salt I don't know don't listen to
what we're saying look at what's on the
screen so I'm sure to do that there and
this is some serious butcher shop right
here yeah we got a butcher we got a
couple butchers did I just get the CRO
bleep right there yeah yeah mother [ __ ]
oh we but [ __ ] stays however much spice
you want or however hot you want it to
be like it's been cooking bro you
control your own destiny follow your
heart and don't be afraid to take a step
a little bit further too at the same
time you know like play to your taste
but get out of your comfort zone every
once in a while foods fun like that that
was like the sweetest way that I've ever
heard someone say don't be a [ __ ]
Garrett that's what I meant
throw that spice on it make it hot make
it too hot for your daddy and then sit
down across from your daddy Derek and
finish your ribs while he's acting like
a [ __ ] begging for milk alright so it
looks like we have peppers this looks
like yellow hot peppers jalapeno peppers
scotch bonnet yep bring my boy scratch
Bennett he got locked up in 1998
look at this thing we got over here
we're going to take all these peppers
and we're going to put it in this thing
so we're going to use this if you don't
have this
knives okay all right so for this part
we're adding sauces we have molasses
here we have a garlic sauce here we have
some soy sauce here this is all
practical stuff this is just what you
kind of need for taste and for texture
the muscle though is all over here so
these are your hot sauces that's stupid
that's stupid you smell that I just
joined forces here at Captain Planet
style you don't have to go as hard in
the hot sauce paint as we're going today
you can cut it with sriracha Tabasco
Texas Pete's
maybe the hot ones hot sauce ketchup
shut it - the hot ones hot sauce you
guys got to try it I never tried it so I
can't vouch for it but I mean you got to
try everything at least once in let me
go into this afternoon
damn start adding complete coverage
leave no rib left behind what you're
going to do is you're going to cover it
in tin foil then you're going to put it
in the oven at 375 degrees Fahrenheit
for an hour and a half for an hour and a
half this is important Shawn is in your
kitchen you got to give them a high five
right after that boom now we wait don't
throw it all this sauce look at that
look at all the sauces enough to like
take out like 4050 father's exactly I
mean so don't waste that exactly you
don't want to leave fathers with hearts
that are beating and that's the other
thing - like a person who doesn't know
what they're doing in the kitchen they
might toss this they might just throw
this down the sink no you save it
because you're gonna use it later what
are we doing right now with this
so we're simmering this - what I don't
know what will that do to the sauce no
no I have someone started to reduce the
sauce I didn't know what that meant
either you know what that means I don't
know what reduce means I think you just
need to make it hot and science we're
making this sauce hot because we're just
gonna put them on the ribs later and
then we'll have a nice hot sauce yeah
does it look like it's reduced in
quantity you think uh it looks like a
thicker paste so reduce I guess means
turn
you're like less milliliters yeah or
ounces everyone's gonna be like oh you
want to you want to really put this
sauce on these ribs you don't you don't
you definitely don't you don't want to
get lost out sauce here because this
coating that we have on here this
exterior it's so nice that you don't
want to lose that and saw so we're just
gonna go just a little bit just a little
bit yeah
like if it doesn't look like your
Grandpa's sunburn okay then that's not
the texture exactly it should be this
think about this for sale at gunk on top
that hot gunk mm-hmm I think there's a
way to like capture it in popsicle form
and there'd be like a spicy popsicle do
those even exist yeah I don't know it
sounds like you got the next big idea
I'd take that to Shark Tank Harley this
whole YouTube thing that sounded a
million percent not genuine sarcastic
and borderline rude I don't know Harley
sounds like you've got a good one there
take that to Shark Tank anyways back to
painting the ribs you know open me up
well open up the oven for me not done
yet one more trip to the oven let me
oopy again there we go so you put them
back in the oven for 20 minutes at 375
degrees Fahrenheit okay and if your boys
in the kitchen you can throw in one of
those every time Broyles so it's crispy
yes every time so I know that we Heike
ruined these ribs by putting the
spiciest rub on ever but smell that
looks good smells like a challenge it
smells great it doesn't hurt to smell it
just to taste then it tastes so good to
smell it Harley thanks for having in the
kitchen me dog my pleasure look at this
like I couldn't have done it without you
yes and so yes the deal could have you
probably would have done better without
me they wouldn't have been me a lot to
do this better than us you know the deal
go subscribe to Epic Meal Time
Holly's doing my show I don't know which
videos coming out first but they're
gonna fly out and if you like our show
well then you'll like hot one so go
check out hot ones we made the ribs too
hot for your daddy ribs and they look
dangerous so you can make these at home
at your own discretion that
need to be as spicy but if you follow it
along you're gonna have some really nice
tender ribs and they're going to be hot
and that hotness depends on how hot you
want to be should sing in we got to dig
in all right so here's the thing about
these ribs as they look at this look at
this look at this you're in trouble
you're an awl man you're in big trouble
and you know it you know what right now
so good so good
oh it is ha you did this to us
oh good not even that bad
ah well you've already had basically the
hottest wing so this hot one should be
nothing to you can't look at my eyes
brother my eyes acting so those ribs are
really delicious guys thanks so much for
watching leave a comment hit that
subscribe button and if you make these
tweet me a picture of it I want to see
it
me too hit me up to a trompe see Ellis
bow very deliberate Harley I qualifies
alright Cheers
slow down for a second till all right
we're going here pays my man like I have
so much drool already building